[Musique]
il faut absolument tirer les leçons du
coc vide et de cette expérience qui est
un miroir des inégalités et des
injustices des mauvais fonctionnement de
notre société une bonne économie pour
moi ce n'est pas une économie qui est
basé sur le fétichisme du taux de
croissance plus on produit et mieux
c'est tant pis si on gaspille et ça ça
sert à quoi ça sert à ce que des gens
comme jeff bezos est leur fortune a
doublé et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire et
pour moi il doit l'économie c'est une
société qui est capable de donner une
vie décente à tous ses citoyens et de
protéger les plus faibles
donc ça c'est pour moi si on tire les
leçons du coc vite on doit vraiment
repenser notre système
notre société et à ce moment là un monde
meilleur sera possible pour nos enfants
un deuxième c'est que l'on puisse
imposer là je lance un appel à tous les
citoyens tout le monde en fait il faut
absolument imposer un débat sur le droit
de savoir et la libre information
on nous a menti sur la guerre en irak
résultat des millions de victimes et le
terrorisme partout
nous a menti on dit pilou menti sur la
syrie où dimension de venise le la sur
l'ukraine sur la palestine sur la
bolivie j'peux continue donc liste il
est temps d'imposer un vrai débat il
n'est pas normal que france télévisions
le monde le soit et meanstream comme ça
confie ce que le droit au débat aux gens
que eux estiment valable et que c'est le
public en fait n'a pas le droit de
savoir qui a une autre version sur ces
guerres sur ses coups d'état chercher
conflit et donc mon deuxième voeu sera
pour le droit de savoir mais il va
falloir l'imposer et le droit de
débattre et un troisième veut c'est que
mais je crois qu'il est temps de sortir
de la guerre économique et de la
bataille coûtent tous contre tous
on vit dans un système de plus en plus
inhumain où vous avez une série de gens
qui bossent au travail comme des malades
ces cas de dire qu'ils doivent prendre
des trucs pour tenir le coup et de
l'autre côté vous avez beaucoup de gens
des vieux des jeunes toutes sortes qui
sont jetés au chômage ou dans des
boulots de rien du tout des boulots
précaires avec des revenus pas du tout
stable et qui eux vont prendre des
antidépresseurs pour s'en sortir
donc il est temps de construire une
économie où on va partager le travail où
on va avoir une réflexion citoyenne sur
ce qu'est ce qu'on voit vraiment produit
de quoi vous vraiment besoin et comment
est-ce que le travail peut être
réorganisés pour que ce ne soit non plus
une corvée et une angoisse mais tout
simplement un service à la société plus
possible de plaisir
[Musique]